tony has cliff in the house ladies and
gentlemen and he's in my faves last time
we were here I need more energy IDP
laughing well last time we were here
yeah I was laughing so goddamn hey give
me a second man I won't have enough I'm
just saying though it's Tony man sorry
but that's time you see almost took your
job co-hosting you were laughing pretty
hard you were doing the Chinese woman we
found it very made fun of me for crying
on tell me son yep
cried on Comedy Central Dyson try season
six point five of this is not happening
I will most revered Noah and that's what
finally broke Brendan yeah I didn't cry
on there I was close man oh I don't know
Brendan's raining will cry yeah if you
get him talking if you if he's in a
vulnerable state or he's been he's been
stressed and then he'll you can get him
to truly break down I feel it scum rat
Tony I feel like you're more like Brian
where you don't you're kind of a robot
yeah if they don't know what that's like
to cry yeah oh don't you you don't look
like a crier no it's never happened
before I've never won what's that have
you ever had like months where or weeks
where you do cry we're alike so I think
maybe like hormonal no not monsters
ridiculous but it's like I've had like
days like a high-price depressed like
you realize have a serious depressive
you have months where you just you truly
just want to end it off like you haven't
much we just go dark man oh well my
mother was talking to her friend and and
she'd known her forever and she was like
I just I can't imagine suicide and
that's him and the woman goes you can't
and and my mother goes no and she goes I
think about suicide all the time how do
you not think about suicide this know
they would this fall there her friend
Alward and she was like well you should
see somebody about that but but I think
sometimes like as far as like emotional
[ __ ] like I will see I cried dumb [ __ ]
dude I cry it like I sometimes I cry at
glorious stuff like a commercial or just
[ __ ] instead of a movie you want to
know the truth you want to know what
gets me
Oh
be honest with you guys all open up
about this a little bit there's
something that sort of jerks me every
time like it's sort of like gets me a ho
ho ho and there but I end up laughing it
off but it gets me so close and I don't
know why but it's the end of Undercover
Boss when like the people in fold yeah
the boss plays the thing and then they
go back and then he just he always give
away so much stuff they're like you know
Sally I saw you you know bagging
groceries at the grocery store and you
know I own the grocery store and I know
you're struggling a bit so I'm gonna
give you five hundred thousand dollars
you know just know so undercover so let
me cover by so it's these huge
corporations like take Nestle or so yeah
and the owner of that you know hope come
and act like he's a worker yeah they'll
put on like a mustache and then the
Whooper offensive and the work next or
like a natural like blue-collar person
yeah and they're just talking like
they're normal people you know they
don't know what's going on right they'll
like disguise trying to fit in here I
don't know what I'm doing here we teach
me how to do this and the person's
sometimes and sometimes they're like you
know not nice to ever boss like oh man
get it together geez have you ever
worked a real job before oh sorry
totally not the MA but these people the
story where like you find out they have
like seven kids and they're both working
he acts like these heartbreaking stories
yeah they always land of it the bosses
all imagine your boss like I own you
actually yeah well I'm not a slave but
then he's like I'm gonna give you
whatever like we're gonna pay for your
college education is always over the top
like here's a million dollars yeah
exactly
she's all I quit yeah that's great well
so I think something that does get me to
that cut when you see people struggle
and then they have a moment of glory
right so like what is it is it the voice
where the family is watching them you
hear their whole backstory and then they
[ __ ] sing and they're brilliant
they're brilliant they're as good as it
gets
and the family's crying is there
watching them soar
that that [ __ ] gets me man that that's
like where you're like dude you you've
had the shittiest life but you sat in
the shower or in your car and practice
singing your whole life and now you're
you're killing it you know yeah I don't
know the voice is always funny to me
because like they don't see the person I
think it'd be fun I always pictured it
being more fun if like they spun the
chair like the other way if they didn't
like of the exact I would be funny you
know it's super [ __ ] up that's don't
worry we're American Idol spun around
they're just like oh you're ugly you're
not gonna be oh yeah yeah that's
American Idol would be like what you
look like a squirrel but he was also
honest like Simon was like I'm record
producer if you think you're gonna make
it in this business
let me let this could be so helpful for
so many people in Hollywood excuse me
sir
let me let me just cut you off right now
you're gonna try to chase this ghost for
twenty years I can tell you right now
from all my experience I got good
pattern recognition it ain't got the
problem with that though is about the
exception then when I know like you know
Meryl Streep she went in on an edition
when she was very first getting started
and someone very high up went you're
never gettin making this business turn
around and go now you don't have to look
you don't have the skills you have
nothing that's going qualified to make
it in Hollywood yeah she's like
everybody everybody has a story like
that
that's what Mitzi told Seinfeld I had to
follow his return to the comedy store
after 36 years or something crazy a few
months ago and all he talked about in
his first time back being at The Comedy
Store was how the last time he was there
36 years ago were 29 or whatever the
crazy number was and he just made fun of
the fact that the owner of this club
that you're at who people think is the
greatest mind in the history of comedy
Mitzi shore was so wrong about me and my
hair ragging it was like Jordan if I can
hold that chip okay Jordan during his
Hall of Fame speech I saw it
he was literally like Oh high school
coach really got me for the base like
[ __ ] you look at me now like okay you're
Michael Jordan really think I deserve to
win that thing like whoa dude but that's
what makes him great like a sign field
that's what makes Seinfeld Seinfeld like
yeah you know a sign fell is a good
Seinfeld
I mean I've heard people go bad on him
but I've only had four
it's limited interaction and I know
other people that have more interaction
he's pretty cool man yes if you're a
comic he's pretty supportive have you
have you been around a metal Tony but
yeah that one time yeah I had to follow
him then and I had to go up after him at
the improv a couple weeks later it was
you know just hello he's he's very aware
I think one of the cool things about
stand-up is that no matter what your
status as a stand above what you've done
you're as good as your set right now in
a way like so Seinfeld has to get up and
still be as funny as all the rest of us
and that's not a given because it's
there are some really funny comics
working and if you're in a lineup on at
the Comedy Store or at The Improv with a
good lineup you better bring your a-game
because in my opinion a lot of the
comics working - they're as good as
anybody push it the stores last night so
I was looking ass I was at Ripley's show
I was looking everyone I'm like Jesus
Christ yeah yeah two nights ago I was
hanging out there and Larry David popped
in I saw that and I don't want to hate
but like you said it's everybody else is
in fighting shape right yeah you know
and you try to show up to the Augean the
four years right he's pulling a GSP yeah
I'll try it like nope the game's
advanced so much as I cannot say well
you know I guess Amer did the same thing
Sandler we were all doing this this
charity that was a while ago yeah I
don't want to follow this guy and I was
like I he didn't when I was like yeah
you don't want to phone dude because he
hasn't been doing stand-up that doesn't
mean he's not you know he's doing a lot
more now yeah but I'm saying he had to
start he didn't want to follow this one
guy's been doing an old aunt it to your
point though those big names where they
might get tickets in the door but it's
not quality show there's so fun like
again I'm not hating you I'm Who am I to
criticize anyone in comedy but Tim Allen
when Tim Allen's the laughing I saw him
as a oh [ __ ] yeah but then you know then
he had he came back later but he took a
lot of time off you got to get a shape
you just have to stand up really is
rhythm and shape and and like when I'm
doing the road the way I am now you know
this is I'm balling man I'm ready
anytime anywhere but if you take time
off you know it's it that's why even
even though like I try to do sets during
the week because
if I take five days off it's a problem
yeah it's a problem for me I don't do it
ever
yeah like ten years well firfer when I
was your age I mean I never took it I
mean literally every single night once I
got past last who's the guy who runs the
company store the manager and the other
man
Eric Eric yeah last night I was so I was
I got done with my set and then I was
talking with Burt and rogue and I came
into the hallway in the Oh our I was
staying there because I think Rogan just
got there's someone anyways I woman came
up to him and was like I heard him go
you you go up anytime you want you know
just let me know you can go up and I
look at my God where do I know her from
on big satellite live fan and I can I
forget her name you can look her up chin
you know what time out but she's a
stand-up comedian Alyssa Villasenor yes
yeah and so she went up in the oh I was
like I gotta see this I love saying that
live I want how good she is at stand-up
because I just saw Davidson wasn't you
know David C Davison who was ridiculous
young guy - oh my god he's so [ __ ]
good so I stayed to watch her I heard
you know talking like don't let me get
up there oh she's great dude yeah she
got up there and at first she was like
is the crowd you know though you know
our energy switch yeah yeah I was just
like no there was just it's like this
weird awkwardness I was like oh man like
what the [ __ ] is happening right now I
felt real awkward and then I guess
that's what she does and she got into it
and she I don't want to give her away a
bit but she had a thing when she talked
about songs and she sings and she can
sing sing and I was staring the stand
I'm like oh but she's so [ __ ]
talented like to me that stuff is so
she's she's a schooled performer and
when you're a school performer when you
can sing like that you've got I promise
you she can dance I promise you you
shouldn't sing and I promise you she can
act only because she studies she's the
real deal
yes see I was working the cover booth on
an open mic night like nine years ago it
was so routine you know you'd go through
the open mic blah blah blah blah and
when you're working there you really
don't care they all mix together and
this and that but
she was the only person who I ever the
first time she got up on the open mic I
left a note for Tommy like with a star
next to her name that said like talk to
me about this person and like circled it
and I literally told him I'm like
there's a there's a freak that was in
the open mic today she's her eke right
she was she was the same exact she was
what's crazy about her is that everybody
grows and gets better you know what I
mean doing stand-up she really hasn't
she's always been that great in the
number seven spot of the open mic in
2008 she was literally in like leaning
my head out of the cupboard was like
what the hell is that Martin was that
way Demetri Martin was that funny at 21
yeah Meechum art was astonishing yeah
and has never not been totally Union
like like with her like I've seen you
know burn though our I'll see you row he
liked that the you know the main rooms
great but then whenever for me you know
I'm not like you guys haven't come up
with so for me where I get like I guess
my motivation like my knowledge is I go
watch the orc that's where like yeah
that's where the real ones are the real
ones and when she went up there I was so
blown away man yeah like I'll Drive down
sunset I'm so motivated when I see stuff
like the whole point and she's a real
store girl too even though she's so nice
and her act is clean and smart and
pretty you know what I mean she still
has that like she has like that dark
edge to where when that energy is
switching at the beginning of that set
it makes you curious and it makes you
lean forward and then all of a sudden
you're just I'm sitting next to your boy
Jim Roth Jeff Ross Jeff Ross sorry yeah
I'm sitting next to him and you could
yeah when she was going up there like
everyone was literally like I was like I
don't do something please do something
yeah please do some and then that is
your profession they set you up yeah it
was so cool well there you go that's why
I don't care who you are I don't care
how long you been doing it you you
better be constantly writing and coming
up with new yeah I work hard all the
time so that maybe one day I could be
nominated for guest of the Tony don't be
so a great Julia Talia said he deserve
and he he's kind of campaigning oh yeah
not really
yeah I can't what I can't blame him he
starts the video he bookends the video
your big crystal I didn't do the pewter
you didn't do the video the whole team
team baby I've seen the videos that you
make Chen you do a really good job and I
think you could have I've seen Gangnam
style before style Chen how do you
explain me not being in that video after
what I did to Brendan that day what do I
say here what I mean you know what it is
you know cuz you're not a frequent
enough guest yeah
that's why did you you you had a one-off
I need these things I don't have chris
d'elia hair I don't have Bobby Lee like
baby Bobby crystally his head he [ __ ]
goes right into obscurity normals
nobody's listening
Bobby Lee gets in shape seeya well Sasso
loses 75 pounds i'm karis not likable
round head guy anymore
how am i competing with guys that I was
fans of when I was in high school on
your show Bobby Lee Will Sasso they're
in the video you think that you need
that you think they need that career
boost you know what I do you know Stan
you know it's weird with driving in
November yet so we I mean you guys
already hit today it's already a running
I mean Rappaport
Rappaport oh yeah the Gator he needs the
boost
let's give us good rapport sitting i
heard him get into it with skip bayless
over i mean he gets so animated it's
crazy man
he just [ __ ] skip bayless is crazy
energy skip bayless is one of those guys
i like him but he's just
is he a writer sports writer yeah he's a
sports journalist for however ever that
but now it's just a Dallas Cowboys it's
a weird I don't know it's like he's
almost like a troll like you can't
really think I'm serious
yeah like people don't care what he says
as much as so unlike it's this weird
dynamic where Stephen a Smith who's on
first take like he'll do boxing and the
you know what he says people actually
listen to I think like he's really smart
Steve a nice man
all of them are really smart they're
really Stevie Smith really says stuff he
doesn't just talk about sports like I've
heard his social commentary that's
really smart like really really thought
out man he's like I mean he not a first
take but I'm First Take you know with
sports for whatever reason what that guy
says and he is a way closer relationship
with natural you know players stuff like
that it's just weird between him and
skip bayless skip it's just never caught
on in that genre I guess you're a sports
fan right I love it
yeah are you watching the World Series
right now I watched it yesterday yeah it
was so cool that Game of Thrones dude
hit a two-run home run with the beard
yeah killing it I can't believe those
guys can look like that look like that
red-bearded ticket warriors yeah yeah
not they're playing baseball have you
ever had a beard no look at me no no cry
I can't even get nominated for guest of
the year am I gonna have a beard I can't
I don't I don't get anything God doesn't
look out for me I've always had to grind
everything out myself
I don't edit myself into that video I
don't have a chance it has to happen now
or he was a co-host you were co-host
right where's the co-host over there
yeah all right make a video yeah we have
to get you an audition for young Joker
yeah we do I met you know I met with the
head of DC and the vice president of
Warner Brothers go it went really really
great but they said that they're they've
reached out to a couple like humongous
humongous humongous actors like
basically like ha totally different
movie yes but I could have told you that
yeah but that doesn't bad it doesn't
seem like it's locked in yeah so you
tell me there's a chance well so with
with a lot of movies now like what does
a movie star mean you know there's so
many examples where they pack it full of
movie stars and don't make their money
and the idea there is that we'll we'll
make our money in China or something
because Matt Damon can sell tickets but
they're very few guys that are even
translating that yeah superhero movies
are a little different because none of
them have ever bombed it's like the
thing that's that's because it's the
superhero prototype and the genre and so
you're wearing makeup and stuff anyway
and special effects so it's it's less
important to get the actual actors who
are movies
yeah and more important thing about
who's been Joker I like it like that
I think Heath Ledger Jared Leto oh yeah
Jack Nicholson I mean yeah Suicide Squad
amazing but that's why I think you
should go that's why I think they should
go with an unknown for this young Joker
movie I agree is because I think if it's
someone big they're gonna get compared
to those people whereas if you lower the
bar well if he's a young Joker first of
all they have to go with some of the
young who's not that well-known right
right so that's what I think too
do you like acting of course yeah of it
it's so fun yeah I love it so much just
taped HBO's crashing a few weeks ago I'm
gonna be in the season finale is that
the Aptos Judd Apatow's and uh what's
his name
Pete Pete Holmes Pete Holmes yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah great on that yeah he's the
promoter yeah Peter
Pete well I don't want to give anything
away but yeah it's a fun episode I get
to show off a little bit of my skill set
you know and maybe there's some roasting
I don't want to give anything away
Pizza an interesting guy because he's so
different than us yeah I like him but he
yeah he's I love him he's cool he's so
silly yeah yes funny face isn't like
reacts silly
yeah good Pete would get along fine
doing stand-up and in the most liberal
college in America mm-hmm because he's
you know super liberal and progressive
Pete so cool that he I don't even think
he's been on this show but he's
nominated for guest of the year I love
people yeah they do know anybody who
doesn't like Pete Holmes's know I like
be such a good here is the guy you want
as your neighbor he's harmless he could
see your your girl showering any like
yeah he's just such a yeah exactly such
a nice guy but they told me that I
should meet with taught at the end of
that meeting
oh so Todd is doing wait yeah well
because his name is bandied about but
then you talk to him he's like nope so
don't throw that name around
no they won't it's positive yeah I think
he's for sure doing he might not want
you to know that he's yeah baby let the
doctor know I've talked to him I've had
heard many a rumor and people call me
hey and I
hey are you directing this and he's like
no no this one's real B yeah
yes I'm not him deal yeah he wrote it
yeah ten minutes
himmat is right on our show yeah wrote
it really Scott silver silver used to
work with Scott Armstrong maybe it's
Scott Armstrong I don't know but I think
it's got something the matter no there
are a lot of different Scott's but
though his main writing partner mask
Armstrong he's right they wrote it I
don't know if he wrote it yeah yeah
nobody's nobody's [ __ ] directing I
was really surprised I thought he was
just gonna direct a movie that they sort
of had written so when I was told that I
would tell Philip Todd came in with the
idea and we're gonna see what happens
but I had a fun meeting with the with
the discus very sorry all going into the
the DC headquarters where do that it's
on the the lot Fox lot is it on the
[ __ ] lot wait what's the one just
over the valley there I always get them
all confused on the other side of the
hill in Burbank yeah you go over
Crescent Heights it's Warner Bros yeah
Warner Brothers that's it yeah
and you love the Joker I love the choke
like it's I've I've wanted a that's
always been like a part of my thing is
I've always wanted to play written an
outline for and some script of a young
Joker movie for the last like 10 15
years I've chipped away at it is it
similar to the Todd Phillips I don't
think it is from the vibe that I got
from the DC guy but it is basically
about a stand-up comedian who's starting
to finally get his stuff going and all
of a sudden bang room everything it was
horrible I've yeah
like horrible so he goes sort of crazy
it's like about a young thing how
certain characters stay relevant
throughout history that's character yeah
what is it about that Keith Ledger's
doing it or like he's an evil clown he's
basically an evil clown that's really
what sort of that's the crazy thing
about the Joker is that there has been
no origin story like in comic book
mythology one of the things
with him is that it's always different
and he never really explains that Graham
how did you get the scars how'd you get
like that what happened when the Jack
Nicholson Batman it does he explained it
he falls into the VAT of toxic waste
yeah and but he's a criminal to begin
with and then but no one explains like
how do you know I'm saying like his
upbringing but like it with and it
changes with his ledger you know he if
you if you watch that when he portrayed
Joker he goes over a bunch of scenarios
how he got oh my dad and the knife and
what's so funny he goes through all that
then another one tells another story but
there's no like consistency or he was
saccharine it was great for me I got
jackets in my all time I just loved him
he was the first guy to Joker I mean he
was wing free takes over God so you
gotta understand when it came out I was
younger and we didn't have move like
movies were not like movies like that 93
I had to wait
93 yeah yeah but you had to wait until I
came out and we were in the movie there
and he goes free takes over Gotham City
wait'll they get a load of me and the
whole [ __ ] theaters like wow because
Jack Nicholson was at the height of his
powers man I went to when I was by the
way too by the way
don't it was 93 don't don't don't kid
yourself or even for a second think that
Jack Nicholson can't hold his own
against Heath Ledger bro oh yeah sure
I'm just saying he Ledger what he did
well he darkness to it he brought like a
troupe at the SEC also a psycho also you
know what [ __ ] subjective since Joker
Michael Keaton was playing Batman
there's that yeah yeah yeah I agree
tiny Michael kiyah didn't work that man
yeah I agree
you didn't like it no see I liked him
cuz he was funny but I wanted him to be
you know it's [ __ ] Bruce Wayne Bruce
Wayne the Dark Knight's like a super
athlete and really strong and all but
you know my own heat and had a great
rich do that with nobody out Dark Knight
in the come say what sister about Batman
he's just a rich dude like he's not
superhero well no no I'm not a rich
[ __ ] guy straight aback but after he
saw his no never saw his parents
if you read the dark knight sirs he
teased his parents killed in front of
him and then he because he inherits his
family's fortune he he he grows into an
extreme athlete and the baddest doesn't
grow into it he get he gets with the
Legion of Shadows and they'll take him
under his wing well who trained him yeah
yeah yes he is yes he's an excellent
actor and in the Dark Knight series he's
already an amazing athlete like he's
muscular he can do all kinds of [ __ ] yes
he's trained he's just a drained rich
dude that's what Batman is very rich
he's just rich yet but he's also going
to lately he's also physically very
gifted and yeah but when you talk about
superheroes they're all [ __ ] he's a man
I assume Iceman stiff he's still a man
guys to most superheroes killer can be
dynamic and touch their toes but a
superhero it's a [ __ ] superhero you
know I'm saying yeah but they're they're
sad like when he's falling through the
air without any like he doesn't even
have an ability to like shoot you know
do anything and he's gonna die and as
he's falling through the air he's like
you hear him it's thinking to himself
because I'm totally relaxed in this
moment like he's a true [ __ ] ninja
that he's trained himself the Dark
Knight is a very dark like the actual
the actual comic book that it comes from
is a pretty daughter fur that yeah yeah
Christian Bale I think was really good
just being a [ __ ] dark dude my
version of the young Joker takes jujitsu
trains Fujitsu is like a regular hobby
and stuff so it explains why he can like
get out of like straight jackets an
extra flexible and dangerous in close
range just like hot yoga three times we
ya know yeah but yeah he's like you know
there's there's something to it earlier
on it's really a question of how much
humor you want to put into it or how
much psychosis you want to put into it
so what's great about that role I feel I
can be these days it needs to be the I
feel like if you know superhero movie
spoke is so dark and there's they're
gravitating towards it obviously but it
has to be real yeah you can't live in
that play land anymore right like yeah
it did especially with what's going on
with this movie you get why Joker's the
way he is and all it takes is one bad
day it's a reflection of the time so he
said at the meeting
that's the famous Joker line that takes
is one bad day all it takes is one bad
day and then you rare the Joker from
Adam West days yes he was an amazing
actor that guy that the Adam West series
had such amazing actors yeah those guys
were such good trained actors today was
good like beating the Riddler's Jim
Carrey though he was amazing
that's another guy who's phenomenal Oh
Cesar Romero [ __ ] what aborted legend
marijuana lynnster freeze but he's the
worst [ __ ] actor of all time I'm
going to put you on ice chill out
you only had like seven lines they're
just you score Tamara was so great yeah
Joker oh my god that's Ryoji right ah
dude the true OG he was incredible of
his hair ah [ __ ] front Bob that [ __ ]
look at his laughs what I'll see Jack
Nixon look at him though kind of got a
lot of his stuff from that right
probably probably that's fair
he grew up watching him you can't you
know you could tell Jack was getting a
big chance though he was so silly in it
you know Jack Nicholson was really good
at playing perverse you out can you
bring up mr. freeze the part where Jack
was painting over all this stuff with
his buddies listening to like prints on
the box yeah it was like horrible yeah
super horny stuff and then the is that
just guy behind him with the big dated
and you bring up like just a scene with
Jack Nicholson I want to watch because
it some of its dated I want to see it
stands at let's see if it stands the
test of time and then let's watch Heath
Ledger we got to realise what you're
dealing with though how long do there it
is Heath Ledger verse track no sans
Joker
click on do they compare it it's kind of
[ __ ] up compare yeah that's like
watching Barry Sanders and watching [ __ ]
some black and white I mean check
Nicholson is still alive so he wins
right
welcome to watchmojo.com and in this
installment of verses we're pitting
Heath Ledger against Jack Nicholson's
better Joker round one makeup and
munitions special face in this corner we
have the zany the kooky the
psychopathically irrational Jack Napier
[Music]
probably closer and appearance to the
comic book iteration Nicholson's Joker
has bleached white skin pouty red lips
and a penchant for purple crushed velvet
by far the hottest girl on any bad news
you [ __ ] kidding me other girl I mean
we haven't talked about Kim Basinger oh
the dark the brooding facially
disfigured Ledger Joker just more
realistic it's a different time this
season's Clown Prince of Crime is
sporting the always trendy Chelsea grin
long straggly green hair and skin
foundation that's just a shade
opportunity why do I feel like Chris
D'Elia is gonna end up winning this
wouldn't be bad
hey how funny was it people have brought
this up I saw on Instagram how when you
watch The Dark Knight Ameri went to face
when he's in the bed and Heath Ledger
the joke comes in dressed as a nurse and
he he doesn't realize it's oh yeah the
nurse until yeah Joker says something oh
but he's dressed like [ __ ] the Joker
with a tiny little mask on yeah I guess
gotta be balls deep in bed it's really
funny how that doesn't stand out in the
movie but in the gift like you're like
oh my god I missed it right it's always
a challenge it's so fun to kind like
what how great was ring though yeah Bane
was great Tom Hardy doesn't mess around
you can basically look up any Tom Hardy
movie and it's unbelievable you've never
said about yell time you know you've
never said you never said anything like
he was okay in that movie
he's amazing there's that one movie
where he's vying for the girl's
attention that's a little shady but I
thought it's still good you seen Bronson
how about how about the revenant yeah he
was the best thing in that move he's
amazing really dude he plays that God
scary dude you don't want to be left out
in other words he makes it what's there
oh what's that movie you did with Shia
LaBeouf oh that's a good woman that's a
good move you don't talk about a crime
family
yes but peaky blinders no how do you
Wallace Wallace
oh this Means War all right all right
all right so you get one of those it's
great in warrior he's a dime piece in
the This Means War but yeah when he was
bein man that's a weird role to play cuz
you didn't know it was Tom Hardy to like
way after like they didn't really well
during about anything like that
when we were shooting warrior we all
knew because like you know guerrilla was
like guerrilla was like well he's about
to be the biggest star there isn't what
do you mean he was when CAA he's gonna
turn him into the Prince of the town
it's a [ __ ] great man they all
decided they're like yeah he's the guy I
think you would make it with or without
CA he's a beast man
well the Machine looked at him yet cuz
they don't really get promoted those Tom
Hardy at all on their mm-hmm well look
what he's wearing that's a lot of fun by
the way as an actor that's a good time
to where he was able to do that so cool
it's such a weird voice I was the born
in the dog the only prom the only
problem is uh who's the who's Batman on
that one Christian Bale Christian Bale
yeah see that's a weird dynamic cuz you
know okay Christian Bale there you bring
him up this is how much weight he loses
that's Christian Bale
yeah yeah yeah the machinist machinist
Oh - Christian Bale dude he's out of his
[ __ ] mind he walks around at 210 and
he sucked all that way
like crazy for that Wow but him as
Batman was weird cuz he would just talk
regular and then I'm Batman
and all their hair inside come on man
yeah that's why I think Michael Keaton
was great I sort of like the rich guy
with the I like knowing that he utilizes
his money and like weaponry like
Christian Bale sorta was strong it
seemed like I mean I sort of like
thinking the Batman isn't that special
just rich rich resources he's rich
Morgan Freeman to create design ship for
you yeah like I think that if they made
it about the suit and stuff it's cool I
don't know Christian Bale's things like
where she where is she it's like his
voice wouldn't change he doesn't have a
voice changer clearly on the suit the
only part that's open is the mouth which
doesn't make sense because you're
fighting him that you're gonna knock him
out hit him in the chin at least have
there be like a funny scene where he's
being Bruce Wayne and he doesn't like
you know what's the stock market out
today oh I mean uh totally uh Bruce
Wayne well have you seen uh when Ben
Affleck's Batman he is the the Machine
like yeah when he talks oh my god yeah
yeah Ben Affleck is not cool right he's
just not my I'm a fan he's not everyone
hates on I think it's good
I think he's good he's just not to me
the level of like a Christian Bale or
now you know those guys are just better
they're just there's something deep I
think it's apples and oranges man mmm no
cuz the Batman he is like you don't feel
like I thought Christian Bale playing
Batman was a step down for him like oh
you're better than that
Batman for you yeah what are you doing
it's a heart like Ben Affleck he makes
sense to me as Batman yeah yeah I know
you mean like like but but I mean as far
as an actor is concerned Christian Bale
now he's not my Batman at all
that's your [ __ ] Batman yeah no idea
it's interesting that I'm not here yeah
I don't take him seriously as bad and
Ben Affleck maybe because I maybe
because it's Ben Affleck and maybe I'm
already I gotta sign a half to G Lee do
it two for you what chick we are on
earth King Lee yeah before you I liked
him in though he was decent in the one
where like he gets uh
framed or whatever by the wife what's
that one oh [ __ ] that was good movies
good he does this the accountant or the
the movie that he recently bring up his
recent movies I've been flying lightly
so I'd watch all these Ben Affleck
movies he's dropping he's he's the king
of airplane movies
he's on everything a good director
though bro first of all where's it at
hold on
no no I'm timeout so the accountants
great live by live by the night was dope
it's fine I didn't see him really good
move really great no he's good you got
to give it out and by the way he's
become a really good director and he was
actually he was very good in the
accountant I thought and I and I bought
that he was you know I don't know never
seen him when he got when he goes nuts
on our go to Donna oh yes very good job
very good job what yeah I mean give the
man through town the movie you know by
the way you're both you by the way
they're not flicks right now like this
no no you're right no no no you're right
movie your eye and you fun I mean you
got to give it up directing and starring
oh and also I'll get anal on JLo what
else you got sir any other know that
right but come on it's Ben Affleck all
right you think he went for the for the
but hopefully he went down Lopez yeah
branch South I feel like he did it
he took a train whatever see this we
[ __ ] up Geely was drinking though
Jersey girl he was like he Paul's deep
in jail oh there that's right here devil
she's right here career [ __ ] devil I
didn't know that movie he put it in jail
owes clerks to yeah I I don't when she's
not good for the for the career there it
seems uh-huh he put it in her jiggly
we're all Harvard I mean he has some
fireman take it easy with the Pearl
Harbor though you make me mad alright
pearl harbors a good [ __ ] it is
you've never seen it now he probably
hate on on I heard it sucked
from who Isis Pearl Harbor sucked that
movie wanna show the war the ISIS review
I can't believe you like Pearl Harbor
that much I mean what are you
anti-american
yeah we're in the keep it bombing okay
yeah not to mention Good Will Hunting we
wait and we get off [ __ ] writing it
was the [ __ ] 9/11 movie or something
how many people would change careers for
Ben athletes many everybody yeah
he's killing it no because I don't I
don't like doing movies no I'm take my
ball and go home
you don't really I know I just you know
you just said hold on Armageddon
you know I get that bull get the [ __ ]
out you have any idea how bad that movie
was no you don't know you're the guy
that almost cried on a credential you're
not it was a hit it was a hit but if you
it does not hold up it doesn't hold you
got a watch I just watch it you want
effects you're watching to send that
through commercials watch an arm again
yeah man I'm old school
listening to arrows he puts in he puts
in some movie time he's got Jews got a
cyclope dick
I'm just saying knowledge in his butt
under his belt arming better athletes a
monster he doesn't deserve the hate
again does that thing with his bottom
job where he pushes it out it really
mean like quagmire you know the truth is
he's been killed
yeah so easy on the hate they love the
Good Will Hunting and they gave him
everything and they pushed him to the
front it's just like the rest of these
jabroni 'he's that are mediocre but
still keep getting shots over and over
again but you're right there's a lot of
good movies he's in but I've had a lot
of people would be great here's the best
way here's the best way to describe it I
think that Ben Affleck is an actor is
always going to he's never going to
really surprise you he's gonna do a
great job but he's not going to be
anything original he's going to be
derivative to an extent whereas when you
see Christian Bale when you see Meryl
Streep when you see I mean I'm you
trigger but but Danny Lewis when you see
that the actors we're talking about Jack
Nicholas Daniel day-lewis a quiz and
even if there's something about them
that is original where you see Gene
Hackman where you see those guys and you
go [ __ ] man they're just they're just
they've just there's something that I
believe deeply it's like they're in
different lanes you know I'm saying that
guy yeah everybody that Ben Affleck
plays it seems like Ben Affleck he just
plays himself
yeah and takes on the character's name
I'm Chucky in this movie but still yeah
that's who that's what he does like he's
good at being Ben Affleck you tell me
Morgan Freeman has Lear's these days he
did but you're telling me samuel l
jackson has Lear's
Wow why'd you mention those but there
was something about those guys with
their animals what is about those two
that you're comparing who's racist you
tell me Jackie Chan has Lear's [ __ ]
me
you're obviously a racist and into Pearl
Harbor well I I don't know sometimes you
can't put your finger on it but it's
like they always say but I had an act
teacher said you either have depth as an
actor or you don't and there's nothing
that you can do about it I think what
sets in a class and everybody back those
are the two things that the two things
that were always bandied about in acting
class was teachers would say nobody in
this room is a real man and Hollywood I
can count five guys maybe probably three
who are real men and then even like what
and then Alan Brando is your example of
a real man and he's able to cry but
punch in the face at the same time so
all of us guys be like we'd be in a
crisis of manhood like how did we become
a real men I go work with my hands or
and it was all this kind of stuff so
there was always this this has always
been sort of a bandied about thing but
wouldn't you see it you know it
a young Mickey Rourke was [ __ ] every
guy wanted to be him every girl wanted
to [ __ ] now no wants to be when he was
when he was young he was [ __ ]
beautiful
I work out at the same gym as him and
he's like a scary ghost yeah what's that
call elliptical where you don't really
like move your feet or anything you just
sort of like it back and forth we've
brought about so many times bring up
Mickey work in Pope of Greenwich Village
for a second and just take a look first
time we've done something really yeah he
used to whisper his lines he'd whisper
his lines and and every guy was like
holy [ __ ] who's this dude he was awesome
now my generation knows what crazy guy
yeah yeah he was so great oh my god a
diner - have you seen him in a wild card
holding his chihuahua hitting the speed
bag
no yeah I've never really seen any of
these Miki work movies he was great in
Iron Man 3 you guys you guys I guess
you're just so much younger in angel
heart holy [ __ ] in Pope of Greenwich
Village one of the greatest movies ever
that movie changed my life I bet he was
a beast back in that movie when when the
guy yeah let me ask you this have you
ever seen seen that change your life in
a movie like when when Ned Beatty I
think it's Ned Beatty looks at her who
was Earl turning she goes how could you
let this happen to you to us and he goes
how could you let this happen to you
he's got to get out of town because the
Mafia's gonna kill him and he looks hurt
he goes I let my whole life happen to me
and he kisses her you start crying dude
it changed my life I went I'm never
that's never gonna be me I'm never gonna
say that I'm never gonna say I let my
whole life I'm never gonna say I let my
life happen to me
[ __ ] never when I was on the verge of
doing it that movie did it for you yes
how old really when this thing came out
so are you the kid on the fighter in the
kid yes really out of movies yeah I've
never really maybe cuz I'm not an actor
no I've never had a movie where I've
been like you're right to rock I need to
stand well but it depends on the movies
you're seeing but you never saw had a
movie question question your reality in
your distance really
really Wow that's the point of art
sometimes no it's true you want to take
something from it right well what do you
think story is about it's not just about
entertainment I mean have you not have
you not have you ever been you ever like
see Raging Bull tax bearing those movies
were life-changing that for me
Deerhunter they were life - how old are
you Tony I'm 33 those aren't light so
the for us I've never seen what were you
watching like not with that man so you
just I drew no I grew up like you swish
up so I grew up on like Adam Sandler
[ __ ] and Jim Carrey what about going to
get entertainment about dramatic movies
I guess in Shawshank when he didn't let
the lady boys [ __ ] him as a guy like his
fight I need the damn man that's amazing
to me
I got moments in that yes yeah well I've
never been a movie just and it's never
like I've never been motivated by a
movie
you never had it Wow I get some brave
fart when you scream freedom osika it's
cool pretty sure Pope of Greenwich
Village came out the year I was born
yes it's 84 for those movies were so
important they were just important I
mean they were movies like Network did I
mean do you guys are too young but they
were they changed in national
conversation you think do you think
moves can do that today be with all the
there's so many dynamics out there you
know I'm saying like yeah so much
content now are you really watching like
I can watch a documentary that will
change the way I view that world yeah
but a movie it's interesting to me if
you have this conversation because you
gendler's Liz you're my guest
telogen and you're both pretty sensitive
and you're both artistic so that's why
it's fascinating to me that I I that you
haven't had that experience because that
was my entire movie experience and
everybody of my generation feels that
way to an extent you think I don't think
it's a little bit cuz your balls deep in
actin especially then you're more
sensitive to I don't know but I do know
that the people I mean it's a question
but I do know that there were movies
that that changed the movie saves my
life my skin rocky actually actually
created the fitness craze in this
country believe it or not I'm serious
rocky created the fitness grace in 1975
people started to jog
well Viva more than 300 you know created
the CrossFit crazy probably it's
probably but there were certain movies
that were like I mean all the
President's Men which brought out the
whole Watergate scandal where you
actually saw it III guess they were just
iconic movies Kramer vs Kramer the Meryl
Streep where they were talking about
what you saw a child had to choose
between his parents oh you know it was
like I don't know maybe it was because
we hadn't in the 70s they hadn't really
something I guess moviemaking came about
it was still a new art form to an extent
we're now it's like yeah and you were
able to see and there was just how you
gonna change how you look you know I'm
saying what are you gonna do now to
release something unless it's a doc
because people want what sells either
superhero movies are just entertainment
and shoot them ups
yeah or true stories people want true
stories yeah where there's so much
content back
then back then when you saw the
Godfather for example the Godfather or
the [ __ ] Exorcist
I guess people didn't like or for that
matter really entered the Dragon which
created a lot of martial arts the last
time you watch this still scary [ __ ] but
put it on the other day I couldn't get
through it yeah yeah you watch that then
watch [ __ ] you know [ __ ] is 3 right yeah
but again shocking to people that there
were they had ambulances outside the
movie theater it was shocking because
remember people didn't have special
effects this was what bit this was new
movie man when the Exorcist came yeah
when she walks backwards like that
nobody had seen that and people I seen
that when she pisses on the road when
she pisses on the road in front of
guests we were a conservative country we
were a primarily Christian conservative
country think I'll hide now the standard
is right if I went in a movie theater
and Samuel Jackson [ __ ] on the floor
it wouldn't read right blood pressure
and back then when she walks down and
goes mommy everything mommy something's
wrong with him something and she starts
pissing in front of guests she pisses on
the [ __ ] floor look at the watch this
this was this this literally it I mean
and by the way Ellen Burstyn an amazing
actress oh my god
dude when people saw that when people
saw that it was the most [ __ ] it was
so wicked see you're gonna throw my
funky communist scene because you are
the beneficiary of the legacy of that
you're the beneficiary of all the
science and all the demo movie magazines
now we see that we go looks corn like
like watch watch the old it like before
I want to see the new one i watch the
old one and I was there like yeah [ __ ]
then you watch the new one I mean you're
talking yeah I know like dry drive a car
from the 70s you know you drive up a
Porsche career from the 70s then drive a
brand new Porsche from today now what
the [ __ ] yeah II thought it's so
interesting The Godfather I mean the
gosh suffer to that you know those old
school
yeah for sure I think came up in it and
not only that you know the way they shot
movies and I'm remember this good I did
it when you shoot film like on MADtv or
whatever yeah you didn't have digital
you're a shooting film right you know
what that means yeah that means it's so
expensive it was it was so expensive per
foot I'm sure anybody gets a beat well
you are you editing with took forever
but also so when you had a camera on you
right in fact in fact well when when
Charlize Theron's she won that Oscar
when she turns on montón monster when
she turns to to christina ricci and says
I need some help the first time she ever
asked for help
it's one water but in my opinion she
best one of the best performances when
Patti was shooting that they were
running out of film they don't have
money and Patti goes we need this other
taste she goes we only have one more
take film was precious you couldn't do a
thousand takes film was so expensive so
there was eager behind at your job yes
you had to be ready and you had good
taste if you were just an actor let's
how'd you get three four or five
you know it's narrow would take 50 takes
but that was De Niro but for the most
part is not he had to hurry up [ __ ] was
expensive their honor so you better get
it because if you don't get it as an
actor it's in the can forever and you
kind of sucked you just got a blow it
was a disaster so the I guess the
pressure and the idea and and there were
in special effects so you had to figure
out a way to make it psychological don't
miss those old days well those old days
yeah I mean I don't know
I miss it's almost sad that don't you
think it's almost sad that you can't
have the same impact it makes me sad
that you guys are looking at movies only
as entertainment and not as artistic
impact no they've artistically impacted
me I just couldn't square it up to a
scene or something that I took literally
like that changing life yeah but
Tarantino's movies and me finding out
about that fresh out of high school
turned me on to art completely like I
started going to the library to like
research him and the movies that
influenced him how about true romance
with Christopher Walker and the entire
all the way back to the movies that
inspired him like you know uh the Sergio
Leone spaghetti westerns and all that
and I went off and good to bad Yahoo and
where I was from an Ohio and Youngstown
they sort of like being an artist like
they don't tell you that that's an
option you don't like that so I was you
know very like self-taught and went off
into a you know a dark like [ __ ] I
didn't know you were from Youngstown yes
I couldn't be more blue-collar right I
mean that's Youngstown super bloom is
because aggressive right yeah it's an
aggressive yeah it's a fighter's town
yeah and it's it's really really tough
and crazy especially when I was growing
up the factory working the football the
factories were all closed so it turned
into a big depressed like Springsteen
wrote a song about him yeah and the
Mafia was there cuz it's a central
meeting place between Chicago and New
York but him but when I was growing up
they crack down on the Mafia and
Youngstown so unorganized crime took
over like gang gang 's and so um yeah
that arts stuff like really stood out to
me and it was mostly Tarantino and all
that and also when in Jim Carrey made
man on the moon and wait Andy Kaufman I
didn't know who there's not on Netflix
have you have you heard about this
there's a documentary coming out on
Netflix when Jim Carrey played man on
the moon and how he wouldn't break
character all behind the scenes stuff on
it I think comes out November 4th
November 5th that movie changed my life
that movie changed guys that's great
yeah there yeah about that was because
like I saw specials growing up on HBO
and stuff like that and I'm
like whoa being a comedian seems crazy
but I don't know I guess maybe you have
to have like a powerful dad or something
to be able to do it like I don't know
how that possibly find the thing that
you can actually do comment I shouldn't
sit like I so when you say like one
scene or something like that there's no
City in the movie yeah maybe I think
humilation of it things like the movie
the program which was I don't know if
you have seen the program the football
movie the program and relevant to you
there's Rouen but then like the whole
body of work from Adam Sandler Jim Kay
where I was using their vernacular and I
was at a silly I gotta go I'm silly as
[ __ ] - obviously not silly gave you
lighthouses yeah I was like you know
well it also gave you the desire to be
funny because you wanted to touch that
right I think that also you know it is
true that it depends on your your what
was relevant to you at the time for you
what was relevant was speed strength
strategy you were trying to be a pro
athlete so that's very very only that's
why the program was good but yeah I
don't know yeah there's I can't remember
any movie where it was like
life-changing
I remember in man-in-the-moon there's
the part in the beginning where Andy is
doing this thing and the guys like I
don't think I can pay you this week Andy
you know it's just not happening you're
not selling tickets or whatever and I'm
I remember consciously thinking like so
there's people that just perform in
front of audiences and they get paid
like a few bucks like that's crazy they
just go up there and make people laugh
it was so because I was always the the
class clown goofing around and I just
did it just because I loved making
people laugh what you do so when I
really put it together like oh that's a
part so that's the middle part between
the HBO special well do right when I saw
you before you guys were [ __ ] born
probably and in fact death for sure yeah
back when you were hiding things when I
was 18 years old when I was 17 and 18
okay when I was I would go my father
would take me to the improv in New York
City and he would take me there because
I would I was talking about being an
actor and he would take me there with my
mom's just to show me to try to
essentially discourage me to show me how
hard it is and how funny these people
were but they still were making it and
we would go and that's where I saw da
Moreira for the first time that's what I
saw these great young da Marrero I mean
it's probably you know thirty thirty but
I remember being so blown away in New
York City at the improv first of all you
know what my favorite thing was to do
watch my father laugh my father who was
had such a serious job and was so so
much pressure and to watch that
[ __ ] howl yeah and I was like
goddamn and so I would do is I would
redo the jokes so that he would laugh
you know but it was it was so powerful
to see I could and I couldn't believe
how funny human beings could be like I
was like this [ __ ] is so funny I can
barely laugh have you ever seen
something that's so funny that you're
like when I saw Ghostbusters with Bill
Murray the first one I I was so
entertained that I was biting my nails
cuz I couldn't laugh I was so
overwhelmed with the funny like I was
like I don't know how to even describe
its unless you can be so sometimes you
can be so awed by the funny that you're
not laughing you're just kind of washing
well you're like this is [ __ ] amazing
I can't laugh cuz I'm I remember it was
like my first week my first time at the
comedy club you're very lucky that's
very cool that your dad took you there
my first time ever in a comedy club I
had just signed up for the open mic at
the Comedy Store and I was lucky enough
to get on my first Sunday even signing
up and may of 2007 terrifying is it
super terrifying I had never been inside
of a comedy club and all of a sudden I'm
on the show it's real it's happening
it's what I wanted and here we were but
a few days later after that I was
watching like I went back to the comedy
store to see one of their normal shows
and just sit in the back for the first
time and it was Duncan Trussell lil hobo
he ever see him do that where though no
but it's you haven't seen him do it it
is the most it is the most lights out
funniest thing I've ever seen in my life
I don't want to give it away but he
pulls out a ventriloquist dummy and and
does the thing where he pays tribute to
his you know grandfather who recently
died and let's just say that sanity is
demon yeah the whole thing everybody
gets possessed like everything's why
it's so funny
it's great I remember that you just
remind me of that sitting there like I
was when I started I laughed for months
after that but when it was happening I
couldn't laugh like I was just literally
I was realizing that wow this is it this
is like there's cool like Duncan was
sort of like a bridge between the guys
that I was seeing at the store at the
time and she's been I haven't seen down
New York City oh yeah oh yeah but so you
came out at how old um well I started
stand-up at 22 in LA yeah so did you
move from Youngstown to LA just to
pursue um pretty much sort of like I
wanted to get out of Ohio anyway my
brother was living out here so I started
I just came out and was crashing on his
couch for a while and and then yeah
pretty much that I had written uh I'd
written a script like not a complete
script but a lot of a movie and and
wanted to try out stand-up and see how
it would go I was at a coffee shop made
friends with Shia LaBeouf's dad one day
in Burbank and he told me to go to the
comedy store don't start at sappy open
mikes
well I'm like all right and at the time
Shia was like about to be the new
Indiana Jones and all this like he had
just signed that super Spielberg deal
and in my RA well I guess Shia LaBeouf's
dad knows more than anybody that I've
[ __ ] talking to so I'll show up the
Comedy Store and start there they're not
a they're not a he said you know don't
be a big fish in a small pond just go
there make friends and get in he was
right he's kind of right yeah now I'm
one of the top young rising stand-up
comedians in the world however I'm not a
nominee for guest of the year okay bro
you know what chin come on you just got
off that big tour - yeah the Monster
Energy outbreak tour I'm going back to
Australia this month how was
Thanksgiving yeah it's gonna be my third
time third November in a row going to
Australia so I before me I granted chris
d'elia access to australia you welcome
Chris gates yeah you manicured the
target you know I just gave him the okay
the past they're the best they're the
best comedy fans in the world
crazy Anna I always thought Canada was
unstoppable Canada is amazing Toronto
Vancouver all this place then you go to
Australia and you're like oh ki dokie
you know you know you know he in [ __ ]
with Australia know if you've been there
I saw that beautiful 'n really oh I've
been getting a lot of I think I might go
to like Europe and June I feel like I
don't know Amsterdam they say it's
really good I feel like a bunch of us
should do like rolling festival or
something it's so silly that we should
go to we should get all the hanging we
should do stand in Asia Ireland [ __ ]
England we should do something where we
go together they say yeah make sense
shoot it like turn it into a [ __ ] but
but I yeah but but I think like a horn
guys I think like do to make cool to
make money to make it make sense is you
get sponsors for it to sponsor the whole
tour you just get bangers and then like
everyone has their night and you switch
so do you like a Thursday night Friday
night Senate but you switch nights so
people open and one person there's their
full headline yeah then one person that
people come to everything because it'll
be like a you know a party yeah like a
festival we're all friends all family
yeah it's almost better just to do
everybody does a half hour you know yeah
it's a two hour show right you bring
four people I'd be sick you know just
look the money evilly yeah wouldn't be
about the money yeah because what you do
is you shoot it I don't know what would
we be interesting we think about it
climate come on it'll be fun but I think
we could sell out and [ __ ] off Norway
Sweden they're all watching this oh yeah
no doubt about I mean Finland I mean you
get there they're interesting up in
Sweden though it's Sweden I feel like is
the opposite of Australia they're not
like been there yeah I thought I bombed
I did two shows and I thought I thought
I bombed after the first show and like I
walked upstaged because like they're so
quiet but they but they applauded yeah
for the comedy they're not but they're
not like reserved like Miami where it's
like a lot of Latin kind of wool party
you know there're states very like when
people would you go back yeah I mean
I'll go anywhere heck yeah I just didn't
know the second show was fine that's the
first show I'm like Jesus like when I
was like shaking Joe's hand after
Stockholm I was shaking Joe's hand after
the first Sun I'm like Jesus I think I
bombed like hot like icing and then I
went backstage I'm like oh my god what
happened in this song guys like what do
you mean and I'm like it was wait why
weren't they that there was a horrible
set and he's like no man you were great
I'm like what do you mean like I just
had no idea they don't pan laughs yeah
like where is Australia's like was that
that was in Stockholm yeah beautiful
city man yeah unbelievable I caught like
I was in a snow globe it was beautiful
oh it's go all the women there in the
water in the main all the women there
are stunning like there's no even
pregnant pregnant women are models every
everybody's Iceland I said about Iceland
and Latvia yeah those areas like certain
magical magical there's no fat people
you can't find a fat person in Sweden
they don't exist they kill them there
yeah they don't America they don't
survive you do something besides should
you sell by curtilage Turan I love her
in a band or anything
oh they'll play that trailer for me Jim
and Andy I get Tony's gonna appreciate
this even Andy cuz uh yeah that one
right there
the great beyond I'm obsessed with yeah
Wow finding out you have something
special in it gets a reaction that's how
I got attention and love
Wow
I'm gonna love this
from Andy Kaufman came in to turn
reality on its head and not stop on the
camera stop you know you're Andy Kaufman
cared less about making his audience
laugh than keeping them confused
I wouldn't mind playing Jim Carrey one
day in a movie about Jim Carrey it'd be
cool and that's the moment when Andy
came back to make his movie hello put on
weight do it after was out of my control
okay don't stop Andy felt it was
necessary to stay in the character is
exactly the way Andy was totally surreal
this crazy melodrama started happening
all over the place Jimmy said they came
down hard who's they Universal didn't
want the footage we took behind the
scenes to surface so that people
wouldn't think I was an [ __ ] I was
thinking how far should I take this
it's working how far would Andy take it
wow they look sweet they're gonna sue
this production for mental stress how'd
I not know about this this is crazy the
man couldn't remember who I was anymore
so you step through the door not knowing
what's on the other side what's on the
other side is everything
[Music]
I know him as well as I can know him but
who do you know even when they're right
in front of you
the movie sent me to the library dude I
read every Andy Kaufman Tony Clifton
every book about his life after that
some french fries or porous turk back
knows I didn't know he was that much of
a disaster nobody's talked about it
David Kaufman I'm saying on the set like
what he was about
oh yeah you know yeah but like on MADtv
Orlando Jones David Herman they were
always in character if they were doing a
character you you just better get used
to that all day long maybe where I heard
this is over the top
yeah like crazy there was always like an
improv and like that there was always
that tradition of just kind of like [ __ ]
everybody and be a day but that's pretty
amazing it's gonna be sweet
that is so cool he's a little crazy
Annie Irene oh yeah I think he's gotten
a little with that beard
I think to be as talented in that name
someone that talented is not crazy
exactly name someone who's the most
health first you know who's not crazy
crazy depending on how you define it but
name someone be name a genius who's not
gassy name someone who's so much more
talented and everyone has their [ __ ]
together
Kanye West's crazy as fog genius genius
crazy 99 crazy
I don't think Daniel day-lewis is it was
pretty damn good as an actor is Crazy's
crazy you know these little weird
working going to England working yes oh
so she's a cobbler in plus you don't
know him put like you personally you
know I'm saying like who knows what he's
like yeah yeah I think I don't look at
this crazy I think I look at it as
inspired and passionate so so for Jim
Carrey he's tired he got tired of
himself right and so he's like cuz
because let's be honest you're an actor
right so you've done everything you had
to in stand-up it's great now you've
been acting now you're a star now you've
got a lot of money and all of a sudden
you're like you know you know what I'm
tired of being Jim Carrey and I want to
do something seriously artistic because
the one thing he was always frustrated
about was he just wants to be an artist
right and his heroes were people that
push the envelope and so I think for him
it was more I don't look at his crazy I
look at his inspired and I look at it as
just [ __ ] but no but I mean at the
same time now this is kind of like I'm
saying
anyone who's done anything especially
that when they're a leader of a pack
like that they just don't think the same
way everyone else does you can't it's
true when you're groundbreaking you just
can't you're not gonna be a normal 9 to
5 now have all your [ __ ] together and
and be you know steady all the time no
way man I mean imagine every single
person if he goes out in public probably
says the exact same thing you know Jim
Carrey imagine how crazy his life has to
be yeah just of avoiding hoping nobody
sees him or I know oh my god I love oh I
just want to let you know I love it my
friend Misha alrighty then I was like I
should dated him for a long time oh well
he was really manic he's just super
manic hilarious and then just depressed
yeah I mean that was what he was when he
was younger and you know yeah I think
that there are highs and lows for people
like that he's whatever's going on with
him now is you know maybe to be expected
you know Dave Chappelle was saying how
he can't a lot of time to get through a
set without so without someone going I'm
rich [ __ ] he's like cool man yeah all
right [ __ ] he's another one I know
people who know him very very well I
don't know but he's another one who has
old that touch of like sort of out there
Ness you know little mental I think you
have to man yeah no doubt
for sure as talented as Dave is he's
just [ __ ] it you know these guys like
the [ __ ] I'm good Africa even the ones
that don't seem crazy are all doing you
know Transcendental Meditation for you
know 40 minutes a day and they're almost
playing a character to make you think
that they're not crazy you know I'm
saying yeah I think talk like they have
their [ __ ] together your deck - yeah I
don't know I don't like the word crazy I
like a different word for it that's true
and I don't think Crazy's a bad thing
you know I'm not crazy as we're probably
crazy in the way that I describe it but
yeah I don't mean crazy like clinically
like rabies different dimensional
neurotic yeah they just think about the
world in a very different way I mean I
think to be original and to be artistic
in a way as to
always look at it first of all from the
outside in and also to try to do it
differently but you know you look at all
times outliers like you look at all the
outliers in sports-entertainment there
then you see that you know I'm saying as
far as they're gonna be crazy
quote-unquote crazy in some way they're
just different than the rest of the pack
we're all crazy though it is weird
it's a I think stand-up comics are
already yeah different yeah I've never
met a comic that worth assault that was
well III really mean this I've I've
actually I don't think I've ever met a
comic who killed me who's really funny
who was normal right
and in fact who isn't very [ __ ] up in
some way so people out see I think
that's a negative thing they'll be like
who's not normal yeah I wouldn't want my
now MIT to be normal
yeah and they all have like me like
crazy I don't mean like and they all
have some weird kind of they all had so
it's maybe it's a little bit like
fighters too like they all had it like
they had some trauma growing up they had
some weird family [ __ ] they had some
snot I could have a point of view if you
don't right if you didn't come up for it
you know if you came up you will Jerry
Seinfeld talks about he goes I just want
people to leave me alone I grew up
normal but I just want to be left
[ __ ] alone that's not gonna be you
can have people who grab normal or
whatever be very creative I mean you're
sure you know sure but but I do think
that like if they just the idea of
wanting to be a comic like just II if
you really go into the motivation of
what got you to do that I just wanted
like I wanted to feel the JIT I wanted
to feel again like when you grow up as a
kid like me let's just take the
overwhelming sentiment for me for the
most part was shame like I was just
ashamed of myself for whatever reason
why we can go into the psychology who
cares but that was my driving force of
trying to be accepted I wanted to be I
wanted to I wanted to figure out a way
to separate myself because I felt like
such a failure in everything I did in
every way leaving my body and my like I
don't know you just you just work I
wasn't cool right you know I've moved
around to a different country I was an
American and I wasn't from the place I
was in because I'd never lived in the
States so then now what I you know
so how do you fit in and then well well
oh I know
I'll make people laugh yeah so that they
like me ya know whatever your motivation
and it's it's always kind of it reminds
me that like whatever bad is happening
to you man you can turn it into
something kind of beautiful if you know
what you're doing if you're not how to
navigate it right yeah like they did
this he tell Tony about your good dreams
made me laugh so hard as when you said
oh dude I had a very sexual dream but I
Ronda Rousey last night that's a dream I
do remember um it was a great dream to
you your joke about having a gay face
crack me up yeah yeah Ron and I at Ron
and I were in a golf cart we were riding
around and then we just had to start
dating you started dating like you
verbalized it and then I was doing
jujitsu with her and I and and she was
really tough and I said I I was I'm are
I whispered anuraga just remember I'm
still a guy I'm still stronger you said
that in your dream to run the route yeah
it was very very hot and and then I woke
up but yeah Tony oh you had a dream of
getting [ __ ] by a DA well listen I
don't
all right listen maybe yes look I've had
a couple of dreams where I was very gay
and in a relationship and I was getting
[ __ ] not [ __ ] but getting I had to
I had to but the dream wasn't me getting
[ __ ] the dream was I knew that I was
about to have sex with the guy what do
you think of that and I was and I was
like this I was like well I guess I'm
gay now so there was a guy behind you I
guess I guess gun to my head
I can't remember their head God takes my
dick in my butt I don't know I mean but
I I know I was gay and in a relation we
did some research into it and it's not
it doesn't make Brian up that there's a
issue
I wasn't turned on by the way I was with
the Ronda stories or whatever brother
whatever there bro but it doesn't make
grind homosexual or gay that he had
those dreams we looked into it it's
actually pretty normal this is like if
you're only gay in your dreams then okay
dreamer this thing I've seen dream
sleep okay I want gay in the netherworld
yeah only gay for about a bi but hey
here if you if you're it but I'll tell
you this if you wake up after having a
gay dream and you got off you've got a
raging boner yeah I that would make you
gay that's not no it doesn't you're just
sir reactor I've never had that dream
well why did you just say why I'm saying
but if you're aroused love seeing your
dream you have a riot boner and look at
me in the eye it's all good bro you
telling me you haven't seen a man maybe
even me when you're drunk and thought I
would make out with him I really have a
deal kinship cuz I know what your breath
smells like and I've seen your teeth
come on bro wow you just got turned down
dude it's not cool is really hurtful you
know what you just filled me with shame
well dude by the son of your dreams
looks like is not the first time you've
been filled with shame too when you're a
little drunk you've gotten a little
flirty with me touchy feely bro let's go
to some current events the guy in your
dream was it Brendan that's what I asked
my fans were like hey Brian stole that
dream before it's definitely you I don't
know fans you're in a relief call that a
relationship know who was you guys I'm
not in a court of law you guys are ask
me a lot of questions have you ever had
anything in your butt no never use a
doctor finger once and I hate it how the
doctors it's tough
I like girls oh yeah girls tried I don't
stick her thumb in in it when she was
giving me the old you know when there
was a world yep you've never had that
Tony now I've been lucky not what I know
or unlucky yeah I agree
could be a good time hard to keep it
together when that happen I know I seem
like I seem I could if I saw me and
heard me talk I'd be like that guys had
a bunch of stuff in his butt but I have
a very like virgin ass I don't want to
turn you on Brian I don't you don't know
about me
there's no story I told on Rogan I don't
have time for well you imagine how the
tape might give me birth story when I
had his thumb in my ass oh I'm surprised
though all the years never had a girl
one of the tightest [ __ ] in all the
comedy
boom all right you got loud farts in the
morning there you go all right this
isn't the one we'll start off with
another one
we waited like a week for Tony to be
here to see this that it happened again
no it's not a real story you made this
no no another elderly Chinese passenger
tosses coins into plane engine yeah
legally it happened again lucky this is
photoshopped it says lucky air stocks
every lucky air it's real Marcy so last
time I was on this lady takes change
it's like good luck and throws it in the
engine and they they can't fly you've
got to be kidding yes 76 year old woman
who's letting these people near the
point they have to stop now well how do
you get near the engine like I've never
good when you so when you're walking out
on the tarmac sometimes in you're going
yeah I've done it before as you're
walking up you know the engines right
there if it's a laser if it's a major
airline water doing it when birds fly so
so in airports it was a little known
fact as they have peregrine falcons a
lot of times and the reason they have
Falcons in like that they're trained
they keep the other birds away because
birds are super territorial if you got a
bunch of geese or crows flying around on
occasions and ducks and it gets in the
engine you got big problems big problems
about have you seen a video did we do
this on here did you see the video of
that those those uh those [ __ ]
engines on planes where people get
sucked into them or we did that yeah
yeah oh my god it scares me
you talk about the suck yeah it sucked
with a suck zone big came from cheese
white Chinese women think that why do
Chinese women think that throwing coins
in a plane engines gonna be good luck
it's probably an old thing genuine I'm
asking you Hayes Korean our crane you
are oh is that why Bobby Lee's in the
video for best
why wish I could talk about this but I
can't but yeah Chinese Buddhist thing
they have anyone in your family have
ever attempted to throw change and the
we're gonna have the rookies right that
is the most I know I have a great idea
how about we add some rock to this right
so if we use this roughly enough engine
dude why are you I do he can still make
fun of because they're doing really well
that's why right now I just don't have
any shame in my game I really think that
I personally the even though she's 76
thinks it's okay to throw change in a
[ __ ] airplane yeah can you imagine
how hard it must be to be an Asian pilot
in the first place
right I mean out of all the racial
stereotypes let's face it
chin you've been in a car accident I
have but other people's fault you heard
I'm not gonna do it even these terrible
steroids no no no I we can talk about it
types exists for a reason Asian Asians
agree and nobody knows more about
stereotypes than Asian people if you
think about it sure well name name and
ID bear with me here but the stereotypes
exist for a reason a lot of times but
named the best Asian driver in f1 or
NASCAR that's ever one go no wait
there's none there's never been never
they end up throwing coins in their
engine and they never hit pole position
very good pole position I never thought
of that racecar drivers all right now
it's just not a tradition just wait till
I get into drive you should call it they
should call it every race except for
that one car driving yeah it's just not
the thing you love yeah do you watch any
of that stuff cuz you chase balls deep
in at Nam I never got it I don't like I
guess for me the ones big deal that was
like so much big deal there was the one
of the like biggest names that box and
burn the Formula One driver and his
girlfriend was deeeelicious
who assembles a buck is that not loose I
know Lewis Hamilton it wasn't him who's
this other guy
he was at a NASCAR Formula One where
they make bang bang yeah and they're
like you don't who that is like all the
guys in the firm mean we knew who it was
cause it's big over there yeah it's so
much like small dude so huge come up I'm
his net worth was like 60 something mil
and you just crazy crazy Wow yeah it's
amazing how Formula One is so huge in
everywhere else but the United States is
getting bigger here like they just had
one Austin Jay flew to it why wouldn't
it be as big though I don't understand
no no they have their the S cars [ __ ]
huge yeah yeah that's huge I can't get
Nazca no no no it's a lot of technique
I'm sure yeah he's a swap paint Days of
Thunder was cool Tom Cruise Cole trickle
how about a guy who plays the same role
over and over yeah what else you got it
all right you guys know barstool sports
so they had a show on ESPN that got
canceled after one episode so so so
Barstow everyone knows barstool sports I
love those guys when I found out their
show which is called
I think van Tom yes Barstow van tock van
talk so they ESP ensigns guys cuz
they're trying to create dynamic and you
know get young and there's so much
content they're kind of a dying breed
these talk shows the first takes all
that they're not doing SportsCenter
they're trying to be more relevant so
they collab with freakin yes our stool
it's called van talk and then I think
they got in trouble cuz he was referred
to a girl he goes man she needs to sex
it up or get sex or get the tits out a
girl named Sam ponder who uh she's like
in this environment oh boy
but but this is like two years ago they
did this so her name's Sam ponder she's
that she hosts the NFL show on ESPN and
then she dug up this old tweet let's see
what bar so it's old so yes they did it
on the show so she tweeted this a long
time ago said blogs websites that
consistently are constantly disrespect
women and objectify their bodies then
take a strong stand again stand on the
Ray Rice issue really confuse me so
she's putting those two things together
it's okay to be not into it's okay to be
insensitive to what
your impact is to a woman when you say
she's got a great body or whatever right
is a guy because your locker room
talking to how you grew up and then to
not be into dudes who knock a woman in
it so there are two separate things for
men completely right I mean I'm allowed
to be insensitive in my language because
I don't really pay attention like it's
like Tony doesn't hate Asian people cuz
he's doing a [ __ ] impression and he
can also not like it when an asian woman
gets the [ __ ] kicked out of her by her
boyfriend you know I mean this is this
is uh but this is confusing to me cuz I
mean know what you're dealing with if
you're SPS with barstool sports in the
show's called van talk I mean know your
demographic know your tan what so what
is van talk I don't understand there
it's like podcasting it's it's just bro
just a late night show it's filmed in a
van oh okay and they just talk borough
stalking yeah and everyone knows this
website there they make fun of you know
sexual stuff you go harvest what they do
you know the funny talented guy so they
wrote a blog post about her tweet so
it's a long one about like as you can
see the woman was hired to stand on the
sidelines because she's attractive and
reports stone's throw away from girls
who were hired to dance in their
underwear yeah so he just kind of goes
off on her like just because we like to
we like women and we think they're sexy
doesn't mean we want to punch him in the
face kind of exactly so I did that
pretty girls wearing little clothes me
too and their joke from and also it or
not and reply wrist look man we're we
are losing our humor this politically
correct culture and this mob mentality
is taking humor out of things you can't
even the First Amendment is dying just
because I say something doesn't mean you
have to inflate it like a giant balloon
and stamp it on me just because I say
something that you think is sexist
doesn't mean I'm a sexist doesn't mean
I'm an [ __ ] doesn't mean all these
things it just means I'm communicating
every time a car almost hits me it's an
Asian it's [ __ ] every time what's that
every time like a car starts veering
into me like on the freeway eligor its
Asian Asia
that's pattern recognition let me see
your face looks like she's attractive
but she tweeted this out recently wasn't
was she found
that barstools was was gonna be on ESPN
so she tweeted out and she tagged the
wrong person
she was welcome to the family at
barstool bought a barstool big cat and
welcome to all your minions who will
respond to this so kindly and then she
pictured she put this picture of a the
blog post that they wrote a long time
ago calling her Wow everybody just
throws everybody under the bus everybody
wants to watch somebody well this is
really important to also I think that
when you are you know when you when you
kind of like identify with one team one
ideology when you're just go we have
misogynist culture rape culture you're
you're not able to then give anybody on
the other side the benefit of the doubt
and more importantly you're not really
gonna change minds you're not really
gonna persuade people to come at least a
little closer to your side what you're
gonna do is just you're gonna when you
call guys you know misogynist and all
that stuff I don't know what it does I
think it just makes all of us defensive
and it makes both sides defensive and
they stop talking and it's what I always
say about the [ __ ] debate in this
country with any issue it's like you
guys are sexist you guys are [ __ ] you
know it's a and I think also I have to
say that the left the left with their
that they're a little bit too sensitive
man oh yeah [ __ ] you're quitting an
unsafe work environment with your memo
well an unsafe work environment is the
battlefield and crab boats you know I
don't know and that's a statement from
the president of ESPN Oh see he sees it
he's a [ __ ] yeah we're good we're so so
so the president just canceled the show
because of this yes so she ended up
getting them yes yes yeah they had one
episode Wow
and the president says that well see
that they deliver the show they promise
so he now again this is politically
correct yeah this is so they that there
goes there that's a big deal for them
they may not get another show that
really hurts them and and maybe maybe
people wanted to hear it and I I do
think that this politically correct
culture is creeping into the upper
echelon and people's careers are being
ruined on accusations before anything
else happens or they're joking around
I'll say this too they are joking I'll
say this too ESPN needs barstool sports
more than barstool Nate Diaz
yeah there you go yeah for sure there
you go big and you know what let them so
ratings and choose because I think
you're that's a great point because let
barceló supports and let them find their
own place and I think ESPN is gonna
start to see that this politically
crushed rules founder or given both cars
barstools in the space ESPN wants to be
in they're the kings of it oh there are
yes these are they're too high they're
gonna be fine all more than fine okay
Pete they could work with anyone they
want okay they chose ESPN then when they
ESP ins trying to get in this space and
goes oh wait we're retracting now what
else then Barstow goes okay you're who
is John skipper yeah that's being [ __ ]
I'm a fan I like yesterday I'm a fan of
ESPN I've worked for yes bein but you
know they're they're just they're making
some no no what you're signing up for
and also you want to get in that digital
space and you want to get on with town
like barstool sports when I [ __ ] up
because they come with a legion you're
talking and Madison takes offense to
this oh my god and you suck and why are
still are still sports 18 to 36 that's
the demographic everyone's trying to
connect with everyone ratings are down
in the NFL radios down in the UFC
ratings are down on the baths every show
all the networks are down there trying
to get this doodle space then you have
barstool sports who's the king of males
1836
and then you do this yeah well it's what
you and I talked about it like when when
the left like says Trump supporters are
racist and they're misogynist and
they're homophobic and and they didn't
want to elect a qualified woman because
they're sexist okay so Trump supporters
right well did it ever occur to you that
a lot of Trump supporters looked at
Hillary Clinton as as more of the same
when it came to about Barack Obama and
they weren't racist or sexist but you
know what they have four hundred dollars
in their bank account four or five
hundred dollars in their bank account
that's all they have and they're
desperate for a change and they went the
Hillary Clinton is speaking exactly a
Barack Obama didn't work for me the past
eight years I'm gonna I'm gonna I hate
this guy but I'm gonna try it out and
they tried it out so there's let there's
none of that there's none of that
compassion if you hear comedians who are
liberal talk they just they just go well
that sides racist they're all a bunch of
white races are they is that how you're
going to find that where are the human
beings who are desperate and just wanted
a [ __ ]
answer to their problems because they
have let me say it again yeah what is it
50% of Americans have 500 dollars in
their bank account 400 hours think about
that for a second there's that damn
it'll be class anymore
well that's very real and and people
want they want to live with some dignity
and if you don't treat them with dignity
and you brand them something is
condescending as racist or sexist and we
all are we all not sometimes all of
those things I'm Jenna Seidel some days
I'm having a bad day I want to kill
[ __ ] everybody doesn't mean I'm a bad
guy every time okay whatever
honked my horn it's been because of an
Asian person well but you are a little
bit sometimes just on the road Slee huh
every time I'm driving there you go for
me I I the only people I don't hate
truly are albinos cuz any any kind of
melanin I already have a problem your
anti all by now no I love albinos
they're the purest and and then as you
get more melanin for me I I become like
you have ultimately even too much
melanin but albinos are the ya-ya you
prefer that's how racist I am goodness
you get chin all right so that Vegas
shooter today they found out that one of
his brothers was just arrested for a
child porn is that what's up to my
[ __ ] who's on CNN going nah my
brother's a good person he this and this
not such different bothers he has three
brothers and this is the one that got
arrested for child porn first of all you
could tell me here his picture and I'd
go oh yeah I rest him for child look at
him look at him and his nose he looks
all bloody good lord
yeah that family the family is kind of
super [ __ ] up their father was a huge
weirdo
oh that's right huge criminal of course
the FBI must that's gotta suck when
you're in the child porn and your
brother does a mass shooting and you're
like [ __ ] they're calm yeah that's me I
was like we're gonna have to snoop
around it yeah that's exactly what
happened to people tipped him off as
soon as they found out about the
shooting oh you're super screwed oh yeah
good that's why I keep my distance
between my child porn and all my friends
the two dangerous things I keep don't
associate I have a different laptop
people took clips of this like me saying
like no and you have them
like I'll find us I hate you should drop
rough okay what where you're not gonna
make it on ESPN gentlemen that's that
what else you got chin but of course
that guy touches kids
yeah that's horrible right of course not
a big one but the Kardashians signed a
hundred fifty million dollar contract
how many a long five seasons I think
that's a serious that they say what you
want about that mom and I know I know I
hear they ride black dick all night long
but that mom I like about him
mastermind yeah pretty impressive I mean
it but the crazy one there is the one
who's becoming the real boss and the
real kind of entrepreneur is Kylie that
bottom left one who's that all the
surgery she's actually worth more than
all of them really because she has
endorsements yes she has her makeup line
which is just for young women is she's
like for young women she's [ __ ]
whoever those she's you're Marlon Brando
if you're a young girl back in the
whoever yeah the only thing about that
is it's interesting because that's that
the sort of association right so you
sell something you put it next to
somebody's face and you sell something
right and the problem with that is that
when you're selling it you're
associating it with Kylie cuz you want
to be like Kylie the problem is when you
buy the makeup it's one of those things
that of course that doesn't happen right
that's the one of the issues with
consumerism is that what do you mean
well so you with consumerism what you'll
do is it's based on getting you to think
you need this product cause it's gonna
create more happiness in your life it's
gonna create more fulfillment it's gonna
make you more like the person you're in
awe of which would be someone like Kylie
Jenner who in your mind has a lifestyle
you think you want which is glamorous
and all that stuff the lifes I think
it's a look whatever it is yeah but it's
very it's it's it's an interesting thing
because ultimately it's not probably
going to do that for you it's just
makeup but it's being associated with
that and it's kind of like it's it's
kind of at the end of the day a bankrupt
kind of but it's it's as old as time
it's what advertisement is it's how you
do it Michael Jordan you know McDonald's
W as a Republican have you guys ever
talked about this have you guys ever
been approached by reality TV producers
we would do it we went on to do
something comedic if it's reality it
reality but with you know reality yeah I
just felt like them falling into the
studio doing the show and just following
your lives just like these guys like a
reality reality show now we would do we
want to do comedy something like that
but 50 mil yeah a few the Kardashians
we're far cry from that I'm surprising
my have to get a fake death I'll do it
I'm surprised this is gonna be exciting
seasons of the Kardashians if oj pops
back in says what's up imagine if he
moved in the house oh my god how do you
miss an episode
it's part of my do it this could be the
one yeah Oh Jay yes yet well but also
the reason five-year deal so Kylie's
pregnant so they didn't have that so
it's just a dynasty cuz you know Kim
Kardashian has three kids
homegirl Kourtney is now the Bruce
Jenner is out so now so they're getting
their own shows what oj doesn't it's
it's one after another Kim Kardashian
has a beautiful woman right that's a
great picture of her
what if Jay came in and just started
banging everybody even Caitlyn they all
know they're all OJ stranger things have
happened
well Oh Oh Jay and the mom were super
close the aperture his best friends with
her husband Oh master ins so she was
best friends with Nicole Brown I didn't
know that yeah I did not know best
friend Christian it was Chris was super
close friends
Wow I'm sure that uh I'm sure they're
still friends do you think that there
was probably some hanky-panky they went
on to know Jay uh yeah I don't think
she's ever seen a black dick she doesn't
like mmm-hmm it's been the race nothing
wrong with everything nothing wrong at
all it's what I like about battle give a
[ __ ] is that what she prefers they're
holding their own separate Courtney
Courtney's not everyone of them the rest
of them are Courtney's not so anyway
will Scott Disick but Scott separated
Scott's with blac Chyna right no Rob was
now there
every string or against each other oh
yeah I know us I don't know whatever
right the brother Bob who's like 700
point guy I know I just can't find his
space
she's pretty mercenary blac chyna ain't
you she's suing the Kardashians she is
why because she said defamation of
character and they were supposed to have
her and Rob were supposed to have a
reality show and they ruined it you know
you know she didn't pass David David kid
together and she would send him videos
of her like [ __ ] other dudes and
kissing other dudes and he flipped out
when on social media like look what
she's doing oh yeah it's an weird guy
but then again
don't marry blac Chyna you should be
able read this hurt her axe again winos
have no idea her ex Tyga hi man her ex
Tyga who was with Chyna who was dating
Kylie follow me on this was dating his
sister told him bro blac Chyna first of
all names blac Chyna don't get
associated with girl named blac Chyna
right along terminally I wonder if she's
a bad driver cuz she's black but she has
the word China South Asian I think oh
really
so Prai not the greatest I see um but
anyways he told her was like dude that's
not the girl you wife up like she's a no
she's a monster I don't even know her
and I could tell you that right now
she's very attractive though isn't she
it depends on how you it depends what
picture yes so this one oh hey dude
choose dude don't have [ __ ] kids with
her should I tell you right look at that
bun in the oven they had the kid well it
was um her meal ticket Wow
it depends what yeah depends what
picture you get but yeah she can yeah I
can looked a little rough sometimes yep
who knows what she was all right mom
what else you got chin the computer just
froze
however I know what it is it's a cardi
kid they're having a sequel so Ralph
Macchio and the guy that played um
what's his name
think your computer's Becca I hear ya
this guy Johnny Lawrence
oh yeah their enemies their enemies
they're gonna have a sequel a spell
that's gonna be a youtube red special
[ __ ] right it is and you're lucky
luckiest on lifetime I don't give a f---
yeah it's a good movie that wasn't it
and it came out it was my there they are
together and it's gonna catch up with
him obviously down the road in their
lives I worked with Ralph Macchio a bit
you got a lot of the roasts the other
Karate Kid for the roast of Rob Lowe and
it was sort of like it was sort of like
sad watching him get made fun of like
over and over again
well I barely feel bad for anybody what
has he done
since absolutely nothing according to
all of our jokes does he have a regular
job I sell orange and some of these
friends of them I don't know man bring
up his Wikipedia - no we're babies just
you know that direct and her writing his
own thanks and I really like maybe just
homeboy though what's his name Ralph
Macchio I'm er the movie I love the
movie but he was so skinny and
non-athletic I was like cuz I'm to be
Wikipedia might be better oh yeah then
we can figure out like what he really
did he's 50 [ __ ] 5 he looks great for
50 he's 50 Wolff great he does yeah he
does like pretty good keep scrolling
down he has kids you're the family okay
keep going his Crotty children okay
let's keep going down here we go oh here
we go here we go so he's in bit on chin
he's in Hitchcock okay there's not a lot
going on there's an actor there's not a
lot of money going on I don't know I can
tell you is not an actor there's not a
lot of money going you don't have to be
a [ __ ] Steven so they realize he's
nine thousand thirteen and if you see
all the himself's that means he's
basically doing it joke about a it's the
Karate Kid you know anything like that
is his that's I wonder what yes to have
another job or me just made a rich girl
or maybe just killed it off Karate Kid I
don't know that's 30 years that takes
how had that money yeah I piggy banks
got to be super fat lasted 30 years you
gotta have to do pop money you know I'm
saying yeah Rothschild money for that
[ __ ] man
yeah wax on wax off [ __ ] didn't there is
no I in Miyagi you know what I mean
deuce officer Haddix oh but yeah there
you go TV he's playing a regular on the
deuce sort of that's recurring alright
there's a nice one whoa this is
Australia some there's a crocodile
problem there and it would be the city
I'd put up traps in the water because
someone died recently see ya later
alligator
i favorite photographed inside a baited
crocodile so here they are they swam
into the baby baited trap god dude and
what happened they didn't get attacked
but obviously everyone's freaking out
and they're gonna get in trouble the
mayor a stroll up they put only one way
to check a croc trap dude do you know
what that crocodile would do to then
that that's like it's crocodile infested
they're trying to catch them in there G
they're being silly is this a straight
half Queensland Australia [ __ ] crazy
yeah salt covered were you he just
swimming doggy pally I would never do it
let's eat people are so good at that but
if someone says hey you know that's
crocodile infested water I'd go duly
noted
I'm getting the [ __ ] away of course but
by the way if there tree there they're
[ __ ] baited put this dumbass
this dude put seriously the meat we put
in these traps is bait for crocodiles
don't swim in them it's stupid and
illegal man they're Emeritus this is
incredibly stupid and dangerous behavior
I'm wondering if these fellows are vying
for idiots of the Year award or idiots
of the century this is the craziest that
might be the craziest stunts in my
opinion ever like let's calm down what
crocodiles saltwater crocodiles they
come if that's the crocodile infested
area they come for you when they see you
you once got into a fight with one of
them before yes but I had a stick and I
stuck it on his jaws perfect I don't get
some but where the [ __ ] were the Crocs
why did nothing happen
that you there chin that is me dear 2011
what's going on with your friends there
yeah bro yeah yalena didn't realize you
were a drug kingpin oh you ain't drunk
they're just guys yeah you ain't that
trunk right now I'll just get out of
prison in that magic show
Oh keep laughing at the dude remember
that dead professor who was teaching his
students it in the corner he forgotten
his phone he says you guys see it's like
in high school or middle school I can
get out he has his phone set up so he
can go through to show the kids the
screen and he accidentally just was like
an axe slide and it's do that ones
happened on a bus trip we were taking
his kids like fourth grade or something
like that we had this teacher mr.
whatever does shouldn't say his name
because Youngstown's a small town but
mr. Rogers yeah and he you know back
then like the day we had a VCR and it
was like one of those fancy buses where
there's a few TVs a movie in the VCR and
like we were like wow we get to watch a
movie they're like alright we're gonna
put on a movie it's like Titanic or
something like that whatever it was but
it was before Titanic I guess and you
know used to have to like if you wanted
to order a pay-per-view porn
you'd have to record on your VCR over
something else and like halfway through
Titanic we're all sitting on this bus
and all of a sudden it's just like
blammo chick god you guys he was
bumbling it was one of those things
where it's like he's like oh like stops
like falling on him because he's trying
to get it up these days you have to
apologize oh I can't imagine how awkward
that meeting between him and the other
teachers was when that bus got back to I
think I have no idea when I came from
Jimmy Burke what Jimmy Burke was such a
[ __ ] nut
I have my mom my grandmother my sister
and my aunt in his apartment and he
starts talking about how he's running
with the Bulls and he goes I have it on
video and they're really good
he should see it he [ __ ]
sit in and he hits play and you just see
this is huge and and he's he legend said
my mother goes oh my and my grandmother
goes oh my love of course let's like
this oh sorry that wasn't the one we
were [ __ ] you would do that to my
[ __ ] wife and I've told this story
thing on there before but I had a friend
who I said I'm dating this new girl he
was out of town he's like I'm dating
some girl she's the best my family's
actually coming to meet her and I was
like I feel like she's a real [ __ ] man
so my pictures you show me and he again
they were in a long disrelated so she
would send them like the most vulgar
pictures like [ __ ] bananas in an ass
and just pour the linen right well he
had to go pick it yeah there's a limit
then otherwise and then you know you got
a hole on your hands
yeah so he goes to pick his parents up
at the airport comes back forgot he was
like Jack and after pictures on his
laptop so his pants come in like oh his
family's like oh we got to show you this
thing that this emails yeah he's my
laptop they've never met the girl before
she was coming over that day
oh my Clips open the laptop and she's
like oh oh my god oh my god you know and
my buddy went to go pick up his girl and
bring her home they walk in oh no she
said can I talk to you first like a god
what you think we saw her pictures on
your computer
yeah man that's hard didn't work out you
came true my assumption was right she
was a raging [ __ ] yeah I had a girl
really normally the girls that send me
videos of them shoving bananas and their
[ __ ] are the kind of donors wife
material
wifey son yeah what does she have Chin's
at it
that was his Facebook page just one more
check this out oh this girl has a rare
condition where she sweats blood
impossible it's actually they thought it
was fake but they studied her and she
actually does sweat blood she's been
sweating blood for three years now
that's [ __ ] big news that's if that's
real then that woman is the devil I was
gonna say on USA Today Wow Italy
USA Today
called hematidrosis oh so sexual
condition but they don't know what
causes it to this day so she's not
really working out of anything big they
gave her propranolol which is like a
blood pressure medication just to keep
it under wraps but damn it doesn't cure
it
that's the bucks for her
they're staying that AC girl Rose
namajunas or whatever's gonna be dealing
with that man in a month right sweating
blood girl you wanna know if I feel bad
for rose roses little beast though she's
a little beast I'm really normally I
don't count out yo on his opponents that
quickly I've been counting rose out
counting her out oh wow quickly what
damn yeah I think this is gonna be I
think this is gonna be a quick one for
her roses dangerous man
she's dangerous what do you what do you
think be on an outbreak down before the
week of the fight but I think it's a
dangerous fight really yeah Andros one
of those people you said was so athletic
and she's always improving
right on the ground freak man man I was
watching your honor though just hitting
mitts and throwing elbows and stuff and
god she's got so much speed and power
and exert elbows are freaky and I think
that's where Rose is gonna just get I
feel bad because I think Rose is a
pretty girl I think she has that cute
little face and her nose is still okay
when she's sitting next to you yeah how
big is she and what do you think she
weighs walking around one-30 probably
probably weight around 120 125 your
height of how tall she a little bit
shorter than me yeah she has um she's
very very sleek I mean that's 115 yeah
so and she stays in really good shape
you know if you see her on Instagram and
stuff she posts like all of her meals
use her friends the avocado and fruit
oh yeah we're very close should we talk
every week yeah yeah
she's she have a man we don't talk about
that I just got awkward she's she's
attractive to me very much she's
attractive oh there's no doubt yeah I
think I think we I think we're into each
other a little bit I agree with that I
think you guys I think she's hot I think
you wanna
uh well I think Valentina Shevchenko is
attractive to me she's a badass but I
think she's very good-looking agree know
the Polish girl of just one Karolina
Cavalli she's adorable
yep her little lean against it I think I
rose namajunas to me is maybe my number
one with Michelle Waterson I think he'd
be surprised I think it in real life I
think Rose is
yeah I've seen translates the TV well no
I've seen rose in real life I think you
on and her side by side I think you end
up thinking ioannis a little bit hot
well that claudia Ganesh's body shits on
all of them
you ever seen her impression not I've
not sir you talking about the the
haunches and things hindquarters I don't
know if she's into dicks but Rose is
also very stone-faced and Yohan is very
present like smiley and always funny
she's very funny I like funny Rose is
like you know drama feels like and did
you hear you wanna it would they had the
press day and they were face to face and
Rose was like I think you're mentally
unstable which hits home we said that to
you honor
Johanna said that to Rose shake you
meant to that stable she gets into her
opponents heads it's my favorite thing
in all of UFC fighting yes brothers guy
it's why I love Yoanna she does it so
much more calculus re-roll and
calculating like a D Azur and it's
always different and custom made for
each opponent I think you're mentally
unstable he finds like their
insecurities and yeah Jesus Christ
yeah well the belt but guess you can't
beat her up no mark my words I think
this one gets I think Rose gets busted
clean open around one or two elbows and
it's just just like you know put a
little wager on that yeah I'd be down
for that normally normally I say you
wanna you know taken pulls it away in
rounds four and five like she typically
does this one
I've seen her cheesy as it sounds I feel
like she's getting better and like her
elbows and stuff that I'm seeing just
off silly Instagram videos and stuff
it's different
here's a different snap you obsessed
with it yeah
yeah I like her I mean I love fighting
I'm into the game of you honor though I
love you honor it's true they don't pull
away John I'm not saying rosy in a win
but it's not an easy fight for I agree
it's not easy but I think Yvonne is in
her head big time big dinner and all it
takes is one blank - before she closes
the distance and then you're [ __ ]
sweating blood sweat comes from Holland
I mean that's where she tried Poland
Poland no I know she trains in Florida
but did she come from the Dutch school
of kickboxing where does she work she
get her training she was a Polish
kickboxing champion yes okay
she's stud you have jobs in the Osby
yeah I wanted to I heard a really
awesome quote because you know one of
the things I say in today's political
climate and just our culture is that
it's really easy to be against something
but it's a lot harder before something
because when you're for something it's
you've got a kind of like really work
out the details and a belief system and
so Michelangelo said the great love what
is happening right now this is my
dropping on this is my dropping
knowledge this is like a segment you
guys do yeah me I'm so rarely a guest on
this show we have a guest
we're gonna do it now and I get your
take on this okay make alive so I said
that's so funny you had no idea what I
was doing I just come on you made it wig
get around you're here even I was like
what the [ __ ] going on right next to
my hair was like my final thoughts with
Jerry Springer's exactly and I just died
I believe it was the great Michelangelo
I believe why are you calling a
Michelangelo Michelangelo kid welcome
I'm Italian
oh you are yeah that's weird cuz I'm
Italian my father owns an Italian
restaurant my mom's Italian
but I've never heard anybody
I think it's Michelangelo well that's
because you're American
Nicoll Italian so Michelangelo when
Gonzales in Roma and Florence for end
the engine how do you say
Bart's in the [ __ ] Italian and
Florence that's how you say it like a
goddamn American no dude come on
Michelangelo in the pay the teeny afraid
well when I was in Nam he said he said
criticized by creating which is a really
good way of looking at it so if you have
a [ __ ] criticism come up with a
better [ __ ] way to do I love that
criticized by creating because if you
come up with a better idea you come up
with a better way to do things
it is the [ __ ] best way to go about
it we are assures that [ __ ] we have a
shortage of people just hate everybody
mother yeah yeah the size they criticize
by creating think about that for a
second and I heard another [ __ ] great
quote about you know when we talk about
strength and the difference and it kind
of ties in somebody said you know if
your idea of strength if you have one
idea strength which is domination right
which is you know the Russian idea guns
and the stock market and CrossFit and
whatever it is I can punch you in the
face cross snot you need that strength
but there are other forms of strength
and that kind of strength makes you
afraid it makes you kind of subservient
it's a dominant strength but there's a
great saying if your cultures about that
somebody said I think was Daron Acemoglu
throughout this amazing book he said you
can you can hold a gun to somebody's
head and force them to pick up a box and
move it over there or force them to pick
up rocks and move them over there but
you can never force put a gun inside his
head and force them to have a great idea
and that's a very very important concept
and what one of the things that our
country is great at and one of the
things that we're strong in is that we
create inspiration for great ideas
because we give safe quarter to people
who aren't necessarily strong that way
but who are creative yeah and who does
it ever wind up there's anyone who were
strong that way never but yet most a lot
of countries still only have room for
that one strength and I would argue that
our friend Donald Trump tends to be a
little bit more that yeah and that is
something we have to avoid we have to
remember that the strength of our
country isn't just that we have
incredible missiles and all that it's
also that remember you can hold a
[ __ ] gun to somebody's head and make
them do anything you want except for
have a great idea and great ideas what
makes things move it's true that's what
makes America every it's what yeah it's
it's real strength yeah I believe it was
the great Leonardo the
see ya laughs go da Vinci was uh he was
great yeah have you been to Chile
what Paraguay what's the wait are you
are you also a little latina yeah I'm
just a real friend of South America so
you know for me yeah yeah yeah who are
some of your favorite South American
artists
well I'm Niro De Niro the Pablo Neruda
is a great poet I always loved it
Marquez I noticed on the word poet you
lost your accent like you can get away
with certain things might just [ __ ]
say I'm from eat daddy T where can they
find your brother we had wrap this [ __ ]
up
Tony Hinchcliffe com4 tickets to my new
Australian tour Melbourne Adelaide
Brisbane Sydney when your voice got high
November 22nd to the 28th and I'm also
in La Jolla California Philadelphia
Pennsylvania and a bunch of other fun
places winning in La Jolla
November 10th and 11th nice 9th and 10th
Saturday thanks so much for having me
guys always always also check out kill
Tony come see me November 17th to 18th
Gotham comedy club and then wiseguys
November 26 2015 6 I think right dad the
weekend Thanksgiving weekend Cobb's
comedy club December 7 8 & 9 get your
tickets next Friday I'm occlusive casino
and then I go Charlotte on a Thursday
night and then I'm at Zanies in
Nashville Friday Saturday Columbus Ohio
funnybone Sunday November get tickets
now for Brian and myself tea fat cake
Tom this is the finally kid with the
pony we're out